Johnny good morning how are you I'm
doing terrific damn doing terrific i
cant imagine youre talking about all
these things but that's what keeps us
going you know ok now i was talking
about an automated strike zone and is
baseball headed towards that that we
have that you still have that home plate
umpire but we have the technology to be
able to tell balls and strikes and you
have somebody in a booth who then says
to the home plate umpire that's a ball
or strike where would you stand on that
as a former catcher so you're saying
Fritzi and some of the guys there in the
studio could actually qualify to
actually be an umpire I mean by just
being able to do these sorts of things I
mean I I really you know I mean who are
you going to yell at you don't have the
umpires to yellow well you're gonna have
an umpire to yell at but this is
automated it sits there right right in
front of this guy that says that's in
this box the strike zone that's
adjustable according to the height of
the batter it doesn't you know it's not
going to change that's that that's the
strike zone for Dustin Pedroia and then
I'll have a different strike zone for
you know throw somebody on Adrian gun
zones they measure them before so
they've actually had their samples
they've already seen these guys and they
already know what size they are so they
automatically have been placed in place
before they ever get there yeah although
our camera angles today from center
field are bit so I mean there's they're
from the side so we don't always get the
same one and you get Falls variances
ought to certain things I mean I you got
to have a done prior to be able to hold
onto the baseballs and throw them out of
the picture you know I mean somebody's
got to be do that all of us you're
always going to have the umpire though
Johnny don't always be a guy behind home
plate cuz he's got to call plays at the
plate or if there's you know fair and
foul so it's just like the lead line in
tennis but yeah yeah aeona you know you
yeah I don't see anything wrong with it
I mean I love my umpires but of course I
don't see anything wrong with it and it
just takes out of all the complaining
from the dugout it complains it takes to
explain
everything else and do you go for
instant replay to see if the it missed a
line or if it's within the line and so
the people would go out and I'm sure you
research this to the point that have you
had a boat there in your studio yet well
we got young poly desert Paulie doesn't
want anymore you know that he's nervous
about automation and any kind of replay
but I they have the technology here to
get it right and I'm sure there were
times you were either at the plate or
behind the plate where you went how
could you possibly call that a ball or
how could you possibly call that a
strike but we but we seem to be okay
with that that aids it's an umpire's his
interpretation of the strike zone why is
one guy's interpretation different than
another and we're okay with that yeah
it's just what even when I back in the
day you know Lee Weyer was it would take
the end of the brush and scrape off the
black part of the plate the outside part
of the plate and say all right boys here
drew strike zone and then there were
guys that are high ball callers numbers
low ball ball callers and American we
got the best so they were always I both
callers yeah I mean there was always at
variance is what we do you know I I
don't have a problem with the you know
calling balls and strikes i really don't
I there's there's somebody and I'm and
I'm not sure that that some of these
umpires that really think about it we
complain as well I think they say well
you know what the whole idea is to try
to get this thing right and if and that
way nobody can complain we do have that
Vince to replay for tags at the plate of
me you remember back in nineteen seventy
when we played the Orioles and the plate
where Kenny Burkhardt got turned around
when elegant Eliam fries and he didn't
see the play we would have loved to have
instant replay there but I'm all for
umpires but I'm all for the fact that if
we take any kind of consider you know
criticism stuff away then I think it
becomes a better game when did and we're
talking to Johnny Bench when when did we
allow hitters to take forever to get in
the box or be in between pitches that
you got out of the box and you had to
adjust everything
its focus it's focused and I mean these
are guys that you know they've studied
the film and they know the thing and
they have to get their minds right and
we got psychologists will say you have
to study and you have to be this in
number to be here and everything else
you remember we put in new rules that
says you have to step in the box you
have to be there and the picture has to
deliver in 20 seconds the umpire tells
them get the box if they'd only call
tell the pitcher to call will the pitch
usually a strike but we just allow it
it's all drama it's what you know we set
it up it's TV it's you know it's built
up they you know your agent tells you
look the more time you take more TV time
yet and and that's where you qualify so
we we say we want the slope you know
speed up the game and at the same time
we wind up with the guys that are taking
it forever and then we get pictures out
there guy from the Mets the other day I
mean must have taken a minute or so
between each pitch and it's like you
know it's it's not fair it's just not
fair it's just I mean next guy yep you
hit him in there did you dip in the box
or we did we throw at you I mean next
time you even stand outside the box
audiotree me of course that's the old
days no you don't of course you never
did did you ever call what was the how
would you call for a pitch to hit
somebody or was it just up to the
manager of the pitcher what a lot of
pitchers took it up on their own if the
managers wanted make you gotta yep I
never looked on the dugout for signal so
I didn't did there was a brushback sniff
our guys got hit thing he put the top up
dallas but when they put the flip the
thumb up it's basically to throw over to
first but in our day you you know you
got to drill the guy you know this is
really nothing we only as we have seven
Braves 1 i'm so we got even did you call
for those i called for about three or
four but you know i never was one that
really do it because you knew it if you
call to hit somebody you're the next guy
to get hit but i never understood what
come about 50 but Jonny I never
understood this that let's say somebody
home would be for you and then you get
to break it and then they throw at you
so Joe Morgan Homer dear
going down why you're gone you didn't do
anything wrong the pitcher made the
mistake because he gave up the homerun
it's just another it that's why I could
never play the game Johnny that's what
held me back the unwritten rules did I
tell you the story about when Bill Terry
the old guy that why he was a water
heater one time yeah anyway he brought
any young field at the end of the year
like I said knocking down for your fine
fifty dollars hey through the guy and it
went between his helmet his head he
missed him but he wasn't gonna lose that
fifty dollars so the catcher has owned
the ball back in a future wild up he hit
the guy while he was getting up out of
it if you can catch any pitcher of today
who would you want to catch oh man I
mean I do you see the guys there you
know they're the guys that right now are
up for the side young you want to catch
baumgartner's you want to catch get a
Lester you'd want to catch Kershaw you
know guys it yeah oh gosh yeah that
would be terrific i mean you know
because you're like a Monet back there
you can paint everything i remember when
i caught on maricel in the all-star game
on it was like you could caught him with
a pair of pliers I mean you coulda just
one seat right here breaker it's like
it's like the greatest analyst and you
know all you know everybody calls a
great game well gee got Kershaw out
there I can i call a game with her sean
paul mccartney girl i want to see a guy
who doesn't have his best stuff and you
know you still get through the game and
you're still calling the game and you're
still getting people out those are the
guys are the catcher's that get these
guys that aren't without their best
stuff or pitching good game I mean an
amazed what happened with the Indians in
the way they've shut down Toronto it's
every baseball is great right now you
know you're all your seed you're doing
but it's taking for effort please get in
the box it's great to talk to you John
always thank you that my buddy that's
Johnny Bench you could catch juan
marichal with a pair of pliers we also
laugh at him yeah well none of us are a
hundred percent sure what that means
well it's real tight it just means
gravette he doesn't need a glove he's
gonna throw it right here and I just
have my pliers and I can just I can
describe that the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience